people need people who listen people
need people who people need people and
then people need people that listen and
then people need people that listen and
do something
[Music]
lazy lover no need to be scared I've got
the answers to your disrepair when I was
a kid I wanted to be a philanthropist
and a movie director but what I realized
is that I wanted to help people back
then way back in those days your disease
why don't we just stay right here my job
is to have relationships with the people
that I work with and that I work for the
difference between values and strengths
as well as the difference between
strengths and skills and so I work for
700 plus people I work with 700 plus
people I have a wonderful team that also
services 700 plus people any other
relationships there's a ton but I'd love
to just hear some of them between skill
strength values at home for values
because I and I think that like you talk
about us a lot if you want everyone to
feel and make them to where I feel like
they're in a place that's comfortable
for them to save space like home I feel
like is like a word means oddities
things like it means empathy
means trust like you go at home and
that's where you're safe yeah yeah I
think we have a responsibility to like
create a home here yeah I thousand
percent agree you know like what I'm
Dirac was asking me today like what my
my morning routine is and I was telling
him about it which is probably boring to
you guys so I won't tell you about it
but a lot of the times I prep myself I
might if I'm talking to my best friend
on the phone or if I'm listening to
music I'm prepping myself to literally
make space so that we can make people
feel safe physically and psychologically
safe every single day to be their best
selves that's it
that is like my number one mission
that's what Sam was talking about in
terms of making people feel at home or
creating a home for six hundred seven
hundred people but what that means to me
is to have belief in seven hundred plus
people no matter what happens I think
the belief in people and understanding
that people are choosing to be at Vayner
for a very specific reason they could go
to any of the other agencies which are
wonderful but people choose to come here
I truly believe because of the culture
and because of the exceptional work that
we've been doing the past 20 years that
I've spent an agency life has taught me
how to be agile taught me how to embrace
change and risk and it's taught me how
to seek knowledge from all people and
arenas it's taught me how to read a room
and stay ahead of the curve and on the
right side of history rather than
paddling against the current so when I
say like how do we light people up this
is a big question for us because we are
serving other people and we work for the
greater this is my question to myself
every single day which is how do i light
you guys up you know I have something up
in my room right now which says how do
you light people up and I keep it there
for a reason I keep it there to see how
many people look at that whiteboard when
they come in and does that inspire them
so I'd like to think I like people up
all day if I do it half a day I'm lucky
right
I believe Gary lights people up all day
I believe
you like people up all day I want to
know how many people look at that
whiteboard and think how can i light
someone else's day up that can i light
them up it's not all about me how can I
like someone else's day up so we do I
know what my purpose is every single day
when I come into work and I know what my
purpose is in life so I can use all of
that passion to say like hey Justin what
do you want it like come on what do you
want to do let's do this know what I
mean like
Jobeth what do you want to own I think
the fact that she trusts me and the team
to do what she knows that we'll do the
best job ever at is inspiring for me to
go out and kill it every day we are
family and Beyond a family we are
friends there's such a camaraderie here
and to come into the door and feel it is
like nothing else every single day it's
it's magical so the hard thing about
actually working with quad is that she
teaches you and everybody around you
something every single day the
relationship that I even get to have
with them is feeling like I got the
golden ticket I get to sit with them and
listen to them and watch them grow
that's like the biggest honor in the
world so as of today starting on Monday
we now have a chief heart officer
alright and that chief heart officer is
uh actually here so I think we should
grab our chief heart officer
I think my vlog moment was one she was
introduced to see a Joe because she had
been here previously obviously is an SVP
and when you know Gary introduced the
name the role everyone kind of started
her like buzz a little bit and then as
she rounded the corner and just like
kind of like great fans in there we were
all like cheering for it just like that
moment you know when she was back and
knowing and capacity that she was back
in was just it was just really cool we
were all just so happy people that
hadn't met her before were confused but
knew that it was a special moment so
definitely the favorite going for club I
was on HR for a little over a year when
Claud joined the team and it was the
best day ever when she does so all my
experiences I think throughout the years
and throughout studying psychology and
spirituality and all these things kind
of started to create the soup the kind
of this minestrone soup of being
passionate about people being wanting to
unlock people wanting to facilitate
growth and change with people and yet I
was a strategist I was understanding
human behavior and how I could sell more
toothpaste I knew how I could sell more
toilet paper I understood how I could
bring peace of mind to a mom in Italy
with spaghetti sauce but I needed more
and more experiences working with people
to understand how we all dive in the
pool together who swims this way who
swims that way who's drowning all of
that stuff so that's a long-winded way
of saying that
it took me a short lifetime to get here
Claude's such a hybrid of understanding
the business needs because she's already
a king of that trade a master of that
trade but she's also a master of reading
people like areas like those two along
with several other people's agency can
walk into a room read what's going on
and understand what to do next in the
middle of a conversation when I left
Vayner the reason I left is because I
all I wanted to do all I wanted to do
was think of people build relationships
coach I thought that maybe I would start
my own coaching practice at 47 years old
I thought maybe I would go back to
school and get my masters in social work
[Music]
I didn't know that I'd end up as a chief
heart officer I love it it makes so much
sense so much sense but throughout all
those years I learned what listening
does I learned what empathy does I
learned that you absolutely need to take
up space you deserve to take up space if
you've been invited to that meeting
you're there for a reason so speak I
believe in people and I see the good in
the everyday I build teams rooted in a
generosity of spirit and a belief in
possibility i unlock people so that they
can become their own champions and I
celebrate the little as well as the big
victories I believe that there is magic
in every moment and that people need to
be allowed to dream truly I believe in
that glimmer and a teammates eyes and I
know how to push that glimmer until it
becomes a full-blown smile but there's a
give-and-take there's a dance and I
think in all of these years I've learned
what that dance is about and now I'm at
a place where I get to work with 700
people plus every single day I get to
work like that with Gary and I get to
work and grow and foster animes
team that's just hungry they're just
sponges and so it took a long time but
I'm here and I wouldn't be any other
place it's also so awesome to see to
have a CD I went to have a boss who like
truly cares about the people within the
walls and I think that's what makes
coming to work so worth it and so
awesome you know Claude is the one of
the few individuals that I've ever met
in my life that makes me feel the way I
feel and so to create this position
which is more than mark more than AJ
more than James Gordon Scott more than
Segal or Mickey to create a position
that really is me right like the
scalable version of what I do with you
guys one-on-one in those meetings and to
have the autonomy to make decisions that
make no sense on paper but make a whole
lot of sense on heart I want to build
the best greatest let me phrase we we
want to build the single greatest human
organization in the history of time so I
think when people are meeting with me
it's not to get Gary they can get Gary
his door is completely open and he's
available I think they're looking for
why am I here I think a lot of times
people ask me what I do here how did I
get here they're interested in maybe why
an old fogey like me is running around
with a bunch of Millennials I don't know
but I compliment him I believe by coming
at situations in a slightly different
way sometimes more emotional sometimes
more heartfelt sometimes with a little
bit more vinegar than honey sometimes
calling them on their [ __ ] and a
different way than he might and
sometimes I know that he's had a
conversation with them which has been
honey so I'll come in and look at it
with a slightly different slant to help
someone or assist someone and getting a
to the answer or the answer that we'd
like them to get on another level I
might need one answer for him or
might need to tell me one adjective and
I know exactly the direction I need to
take a conversation Gary and I speak all
the time we're in constant communication
and actually we're two sides of the same
coin
in lockstep when it comes to heart and
hustle I mean we're really focused on
creating the greatest honey Empire of
all time what I've learned from working
with Gary is a completely just level of
patience a completely different level of
accountability a completely different
level of humility I've learned to let go
of the 99% of stuff that you don't need
and really focus on that number one
percent Northstar together Gary and I
marry the heart in the hustle I create
the strategic direction for all things
people alongside Gary who creates the
strategic vision for all things business
and together with our team we are
building the greatest honey empire
fueled by people operating at the top of
their game simply put I'm in the people
business I touch anything and everything
that has to do with the people at
vaynermedia and their experiences
okay you know what y'all saw him back I
know she's coming back we're gonna call
[Music]
don't
[Music]